[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want whatever we want
what's in sherry's bag right now yeah
what do you got
is that ketchup no baby what is that oh
a receipt
receipt all right what's in sherry's bag
this is a recipe
and tell what do you got because i was
going to get my chapstick and all right
unless we're here
what you're buying from everything
safely
what's that okay
what's the difference between chapstick
and lip balm lip that one's thick
and like like oh my god jesus
oh my god dude what i have big lips so
when girls get ready for a [ __ ]
they have to use both or do they just
use one no first of all you don't need
to get ready
uh for a [ __ ] that's what it was for
it was luke everything you have is
enough
saliva goes a long way honey oh [ __ ] dry
mouth chicks are you [ __ ]
face [ __ ] i thought that was the main
purpose for the the stick
for this there's nothing going on so
joe's like making all the jiggy's like i
think you should get ready for my blog
you know what i actually i'm curious i'm
curious do you guys have a preference
of like if the girl's hair is down or up
oh
good question good question for uh if
i'm getting my dick sucked i'm just
thankful that it's happening
i think you think we're a lot more
deeper than we thought but
it is funnier with the hairs like this
you're gonna [ __ ] stop her yo what
the [ __ ] is with your hair
she could be holding it she'd be holding
a razor and shaving her own head and i'm
like i'm so glad this is happening
you're like how dare you not come
through with a french braid dude bart
always holds my hair and he'll start
braiding it for me
yeah how do you focus i use hydrogen
peroxide and also like bleach and all
that stuff oh very
very good with the aluminum foil
did i put the astronaut helmet on yeah
yeah yeah oh my god no when guys get a
[ __ ] i think
you missed the next three or four senses
you're like oh [ __ ] nelson you can't
[ __ ] hear anymore your eyes closed
you're like oh you don't even know what
the [ __ ] happening
with a stun gun you know yeah yeah very
good thank you very good thank you
here's what they're i want to see the
guy that's getting his dick sucked and
he's just like
the [ __ ] are you doing your
you're not ready for this i know where's
your lip balm
no you don't need lip balm you just need
saliva honey i know i was just kidding
jokes on jokes okay from a scale of one
to ten how horny are we
one one being the most
that was really fast think about it are
you okay
morning you're not morning horny i'm not
morning running i'm like afternoon horny
i'm usually not horny when i come here
when you come here how many times have
you came here
oh maybe five yeah wow i jacked off on a
table
in my office and i came on the table
because the table is in here oh no it's
over there what the [ __ ] guys yeah
no no this is sacred this is sacred have
you signed the table yet you should sell
it
oh that's a good idea yeah we need the
extra mumma why why didn't you put
something out first
why'd you just do it straight to the
table by the way it wasn't my idea
because i don't feel horny when i come
into this office
okay so somebody made you jerk off at
the table yes yeah i had to record it
oh yeah why don't you go home and do
that because i'm being extorted right
now by somebody that i like
and then they're saying that um you have
to do this or else
uh they're gonna expose me so i was
scared wait you recorded a video as like
um uh under direct blackmail yeah
blackmail situation
yeah yeah yeah because she said she'll
leave me if i don't do it
this guy's life is so weird
can you set up a tripod or you just lean
your phone against something
uh or you took one of these cameras over
there
that's why the camera's angled off all
weird well
first i remember i had food coma because
it was
such a big meal so i was on my already
starting like that
and then she told me
and it is like story started it is hard
to like
sexual i started off with the largest
meal of my life
it was a bag of french fries and three
yup review god damn it
okay finish this off and then i mean
finish your box
no pun intended truly was not on purpose
and then i i have a thought
okay i was told to do it
and i said well [ __ ] i'm kind of horny
anyway let's roll
wait what's the point of the [ __ ]
food coma i'm still with david
he's trying to take us there i'm trying
to create like a funny image because
it's not even
are you bloated i'm [ __ ] bloated and
i'm on the phone like this with my belly
out like this
oh no she said it so i was like well
[ __ ]
i am kind of horny so let's roll and
then i went to that
that desk and then i propped it up and
then i started beating off
and then i was like [ __ ] i need
something because i actually get turned
off watching myself beating off
because i that's a that's fair i i don't
want to see myself
jack and tears us weird yeah we get it
you're straight let me get
no no no it's not i don't know do you
get horny watching yourself
yes you do yeah do you i've never
i've actually never done uh that's a
that's weird
no why is it weird the woman's body is
hot very much
it's not about a gender thing it's just
you see yourself every day
there's nothing novel about it so
and then yeah and for me i don't i don't
want to watch it
all day right like it doesn't make me
horny that's sure i don't want to see no
penis
yeah especially my own yeah things done
to it that makes me turned on
true that's true okay so anyways i prop
it up and i'm like this ain't working
for me
and then so like she sent me a little
something i had the prop of my laptop
and i had the video i had that going so
i was watching the laptop meeting and i
went oh [ __ ] i'm gonna bust
and i went i don't know where the bus
they're like on the table okay bam and i
shot
it on and i was like oh and i fell down
and i went to sleep sometimes
again on the ground on the floor
sometimes i wish we could cut from you
telling this story to oprah sitting
there like this
like listening what else yeah what else
i've never i feel like that's like high
school horniness type of [ __ ] that is
that's like from high school in terms of
uh
busting out the phone the laptop the
angle the communication like a certain
age
the level of work depends on how much
sex you have because that's a lot i
[ __ ] down though
that's totally down a lot yeah but i
gotta say i was pretty impressed by the
amount
you're like i was like that's pretty
that's a big list raging waters how did
you resist not
getting a piece of paper and then
drawing the outline of her dick on the
paper
that's very good and then i've never
done that i've never done it either but
if i'm like if i'm at a desk
just write it out like that at a desk
and i have crayons and a piece of paper
oh that'd be cute and romantic like if
you like
jizz on uh jio's like stomach and then
like we draw and she gets a tattooed
you guys are gross oh my god did you
guys ever get those
uh [ __ ] nrbs in high school out of
nowhere oh all the time what's nrb's no
reason boners
like your 80 year old professor who's a
male's talking to you and also your dick
it's something you're like why what is
happening oh like
how confusing for you randomly have a do
you randomly have a boner and it just
once again a fight with the keys in your
pocket
you're out why you people fight with
that guy also hilarious how guys just
keep everything in their pockets like i
can't even imagine
keys in your pocket how annoying that's
what's like your wallet
how annoying and like guys like this is
so not attractive to me
when there's literally that wallet
imprint on denim
i'm like even when you take it out 80
year old man what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
who the [ __ ] are you hanging out with i
think i'm i'm only dating men with them
with the pocket the phone the only one
person
no i want to talk about okay so you're
from the food coma
situation it's kind of [ __ ] up that we
go on dates and we get so
full and then we're like trying to [ __ ]
and it's like i'm so full
like i'm gassy from the garlic like you
know what i mean i'm like don't eat that
much if you know you're gonna hook up
but then it's like we're drinking i need
to eat so i'm not too drunk it's like
all these factors it's i should go on a
walk
afterwards yeah so like just like yeah
walk
yeah far look over there hey
oh my god the amount of like times like
i will silently fart when i'm with
someone it's like oh really
oh my god but what if it smells you
touch shoulders when you fart you go
do you guys ever do noise replication so
like
you fart but then you make a another
noise real quick
that's what that was just just start
beat boxing oh you're really good at
beatboxing it's like thank you
look we're moving at all oh [ __ ] dude
anytime i accidentally farted at school
that's what i started doing just all
kinds i would just start just having
[ __ ] i'd be a drummer all of a sudden i
still remember the most mortifying thing
that it's not happened to me but
somebody else it was his girl named
uh michelle right and we had michelle
no her name was michael she was indian
oh okay yeah okay all right relax
no no no there are also indian people in
this world no okay but
um miesha was a larger girl and she was
like really goofy very awkward and we
all we had pe in the morning
so in the auditorium everything echoes
it's super [ __ ] loud and you just
hear like this mic piece
and we're doing sit-ups right what and
this guy he had a southern accent
one two
the loud and it echoed everywhere and
then literally the pe teacher's like
don't y'all laugh because flatulence
is not
[Laughter]
he's like trying and he starts crying
laughing
at this girl oh my god i'm mortified but
obviously we're
laughing dude you guys yeah
flatulence is a natural thing and he's
crying laughing yelling at us
oh the worst funny though like it
doesn't matter how old and mature
refined you are especially to a girl
funny hey everyone today's video is
brought to you by
babble babble
i've taken a lot of different language
courses before and a lot of them don't
teach with i think application in mind
and i'm actually excited because um
once all this stuff opens up i do want
to go to mexico there's a lot of
beautiful things that are
in central mexico that i'd like to see
and i need to brush up on my spanish
mucho bonita yeah it'll help out exactly
with me talking to my
abuelita or my ma or my
madre in-law
abuelita you know like it would just
help to connect and talk to some of
geo's relatives some more
and luckily for me spanish is one of
the 14 courses that they offer in battle
there's also spanish german italian
french french
yeah pale blue francaise poquito
perfect and the cool thing about babble
2 is like
15 minute lessons so you could learn on
the go and i thought this was pretty
perfect because
me too in espanol speaking the spanish
and a messy co i could like listen to it
on the cab ride or whatever and start
picking things up and really get like
total immersion right you're in the
culture you're listening to it you're
hearing the app
and i think we learned the fastest that
way yeah and it's also designed by over
a hundred
language experts so they really
understand
what are the first words and key phrases
that you need
to use and also the easiest way to learn
plus babel has the speech recognization
technology where like you say it and
they help you
with pronunciation and i thought that
was real cool yeah that really helps out
so they don't go okay and right now they
got a really cool deal if you purchase
babble.com for three months you'll get
an additional
three months for free that is six months
for the price of three make sure
babel.com
off the record that's b a b b e l dot
com slash
off the record that's babble.com that's
with two b's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash off the record everybody
every thank you
you know it's like oh in high school the
worst but in high school
that's your identity for the yeah you're
[ __ ] smart girl dude
i had a i knew a chick who i used to
hang out with a girl
far girl was a superhero i i i
hung out with this chick in middle
school first day of high school she gets
[ __ ] on by a bird before
period oh no oh my god never talk to her
she's a bird girl you can't talk to her
that's your reputation
girl no no hey steve whoa
oh no i don't know merchant damn will
she do your name oh yeah i don't know
how yeah
has anything like that happened to y'all
where you were nervous this was gonna
[ __ ]
like define you no as a kid i farted in
my
when i was sleeping in class and it woke
me up
i used to sleep all the time in class
and my biggest fear like when you right
when you wake up you're like
did i fart like for us it was the no
reason boner so if
you took a nap in class your dick would
wake up it'd be [ __ ] hard
rock hard i remember too like i was in
ken i fell asleep in class and the
[ __ ] bell rung
everybody left and i was just i was just
at the table like this for another five
minutes so you have any questions
i'm like yes yes i do so i just had to
keep talking to her until my [ __ ]
boner went away well would you tuck it
yeah how big
but people also see you moving in all
kinds of [ __ ]
right i had to flip it up where it's on
the belt
also this is during the time where denim
was very very hard and not flexible
anchor blue shout out to anchor blue
baby
did you guys do this method yeah oh my
god
get a binder so so one time this is kind
of in the vein i'm talking a little bit
now go ahead no no no finish it off
that's right there so i
when we started our periods i swear to
buddha i did not know how
to wear a pad it was always too high or
too low yeah yeah
i would still just leak like i would
just still leave like the pad would be
like
like way back there or like way up here
yeah
yeah you're getting your ass you don't
know where your [ __ ] is
no it's just because you're on santa no
[ __ ] and then your underwear shifts too
so
why don't you put it on the [ __ ] and
then put your underwear because it
doesn't work like that because the
sticky part's on the bottom
i know but solutions so then i remember
we i had uniform i would wear khakis
and one time like the blood was like in
the front no
so then i had to put my sweater around
my waist but this way like a [ __ ] i
was about to take your order
no you just gotta go outside and start
saying stupid [ __ ] it's like god man i
really love ketchup dude it's all over
the place it's just like running out
of the ketchup girl where did she get
the hot dog
ketchup girl um no i i yeah things like
that would happen to me all the time
like
or oh my god i remember one time i fell
asleep in class
and i don't know if i was sick or i was
just like allergies or whatever
i wake up and have so much snot it was
stuck to the table it was like
the snot was like stuck to the table and
i pulled up and i'm like oh [ __ ] like
you're so hot
[Music]
i'm fine as [ __ ] that's why i got no
booty my [ __ ] wet for sure i mean
honestly somehow mine's still [ __ ]
soaked you're still there
all right um those period moments always
happen in high school to girls though
i had that happened to my friend too and
she had to do the the [ __ ] sweater
out in the front thing
i'm 31 and i'm still leaking because i'm
just like
one oh right i have to [ __ ] change my
tampon you know what about yeah yeah
same
it's i'm literally do you have to double
it you have to have the tampon
and the pad girls with the little string
on the side of their shorts
oh that's rough you should have pulled
it you should have pulled it why didn't
you
what kind of bully are you bullied or
better dude yeah come on dude
i've never talked to a bursting girl
again one time can you imagine just like
being 31 right now at the pool like
laying out in your champion
it happens i've seen is there a better
method yeah you put it in your [ __ ] you
put it you open it and then you put the
string in there right
close it right right but can tampons be
better do we need to up it or no
i don't think so okay me neither i mean
you already thought about the gay
fortune cookies
right we can't rebrand we rebrand one
thing this is a stupid question
i i feel like it's probably a super
question should this place
true good should tampons be wet or
lubricated already somehow
interesting right yeah is it hard to put
in no it's a plastic tube thing you pop
it in
yeah so when i stick it in my ass like
this is pretty easy no but i've seen it
does your ass stop bleeding yet yes yeah
okay just i wanted to check in about it
it's pretty cool like the contraption is
pretty cool it's like a plastic thing
and it inserts and then you pull it yeah
[ __ ] vaccine it's pretty [ __ ]
fantastic
but here's the thing though once if you
put it up there the smooth entrance
always
yeah um but well unless you're really
dry and
not [ __ ] like bleeding at all yeah
but [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
put it up there thinking there will be
blood three hours later there was never
blood
that [ __ ] happened you were pulling
like literally uh
i haven't even described it just because
it's my mouth a [ __ ] yeah you might
have a dry mouth yes it hurts it's all
this little flexibility yeah it's gonna
[ __ ] hurt
it's dry yes cotton mouth yeah cotton
[ __ ]
does cotton stay up there what i don't
know oh exactly
because you're bleeding so it's coming
yeah it'll eventually come out but i
would say maybe in that
especially in that process [ __ ] woman
man dry as hell [ __ ] you know
so much especially the whole birth
control thing so then we can enjoy like
cream pies here's the thing though i
actually have never been on birth
control
anything like with their hormones like
acne
some people gain weight lose weight i
never understood the the idea
of guys being embarrassed to go pick up
tampons and pads because
clearly it's not for you meaning like
what the [ __ ] is this or condoms yeah
anything any of that stuff the
embarrassment of this okay
we just need to shatter the [ __ ]
stigma around normal things oh she's
back in that lab
here we go i never even understood to
begin with what's this why do people get
embarrassed well even like getting
even getting plan b you know things like
that i recently had to get a plan b i'm
like oh whatever can i get plenty
you know what i mean it's like let's
just be normal about things that we go
through murderer now dude
right it's a religious thing right if
you get a plan b then you [ __ ] hate
god in life
what's plan a then you [ __ ] pieces
it's very religious here by the way
right supposed to be pulled out
oh and then plan b's like time period is
two weeks right
no 72 hours i don't know anything i
probably have multiple kids
wow i'm one of his daughters that only
makes sense
now it makes sense i'm actually your
daughter not your twin
um really it's 72 hours
yeah because you busted so good okay
that oh
you look like me right there you
actually did look like me right there
you look like me right there i i this
one
that's how much we [ __ ] side by side
side by side you guys sit together
normal face he goes
we have mono lids we have chubby cheeks
we have okay and also like
we have very defined uh cupid bows what
oh yeah
what is it what's that what's it's like
very sharp you guys look like asian
babies
you guys because david looks like every
asian baby don't say that my
head is rounder i have a rounder head
you got uh same
no i'm
oh my god we have attached ears we don't
have similar nose nose is not similar no
not not but i mean it's not what about
profile good profile eyebrows are pretty
cool yeah look the other way david oh
wait no that's good i don't know
what do you guys think a little bit a
little bit david just looks angrier
this is like one of those instagram
filters i know you know that's why we
face swap them
it's the same person you know instagram
filters so you can make out with
yourself
there's something about you that i
really like
we're just narcissists i think that's
what it is yeah i'm gonna sit here for
the rest of this one
i literally [ __ ] myself right now i
swear to god oh my god literally can you
even imagine
well that's the thing i when couples
start dating like
people say they start looking like okay
no you don't you two don't look like but
because taika looks like both of you i'm
like oh interesting this is like this is
like 100 years of a relationship this is
the final four
have you seen that meme or whatever of
the like picture of all the asian people
when they look exactly
wait is that real are they talking about
aren't they that quadruple bullets or
what
or or uh i don't know if that was real
but i know what you're talking about
why is it so funny it's [ __ ] up it's
so funny i need a hat now that's what i
i know
joe got a hat where's your other one
this one is like
this is like
my head is so much bigger than yours i
feel like it's not i'm also so hungover
and swollen
can you go milady milady
we can be our we can go on tour together
do our hat bit
like
thank you so much you look like like
this is like
like neo vibes okay oh my god my hat
smells so bad
so much i'm sorry it's been through so
much no no it's bad i
i wear this hat every [ __ ] day i
cannot find a duplicate how do you if i
don't wear it i don't know who i am i
cleaned or how do you clean it
i guess i could clean it yeah joe says
he goes in the shower with it
you said that yeah with the hat i just
walk in the shower i think one of the
kenja's members makes hats like this
yeah
like custom oh anthony anthony has
anthony has one but one of the members
one of the members of custom makes these
hats
have to be in touch yeah i guess i could
just like throw money at the problem and
tell someone to make an exact duplicate
notice the detail a lot of people don't
know the details there's a braid right
there sis
you get a you can get that made for like
six seven hundred bucks
that's a lot holy [ __ ] i might as well
get the surgery to make my
scalp skin it looks like a hat there you
go you're perfect just attach it to your
head permanently go to disney get an
indiana jones hat
it's super close i love disneyland i
recently went oh lucky
you wanna go yes yeah okay
this eye contact is it's so weird
because she looks like
we all know i was like everything
[Music]
[Music]
you